oh dude
this is crazy that Tory Lane got [__]
convicted a sentence to 10 years for
shooting Megan the stallions foot
dude
honestly
you deserve three years for shooting
someone's foot
who's gonna disagree honestly who who's
gonna disagree
probably the foot is the most mistaken
shot body part there is
right and wasn't he just doing the dance
dance [__] dance and shot
he probably didn't mean to
10 Years bro
I I get it but whoa bro I also
if
both he shot both feet
well now we're looking at some [__]
hard time actually
uh you know what this is me as the judge
Tori I would love to give you only three
years but the truth is it doesn't feel
like an accident because you got both
feet so 10 years Clank
um
both feet wow okay well then it maybe
wasn't an accident
but here's the deal dude if someone shot
my feet I wouldn't want them to go to
jail for 10 years
I might want him to do a year
for real if you shoot my feet if you
shoot both feet definitely at least a
year
what do you guys think honestly how many
years should you get for getting shot in
the foot
and then how many years for shooting
someone in both feet
you're still shooting a person but it's
like not a fatal shot you didn't mean to
I don't know man tough [__]
Megan the stallion is [__] dope
though remember when Tory Lanez got up
and he was the same height
when he was sitting down he stood up
he's like five six and he and he and
he's got a bad hairline but the thing is
it wouldn't be that bad if he was tall
right if you're short and have a bad
hairline you're kind of [__] but
apparently but he could spit them bars
right
I mean he could really spit them bars
can he
um
but why we got 10 [__] years for
shooting someone's foot both feet
that sucks what are you in here for
shooting someone's feet
imma [__] you now
I know
that's how that goes who's that rapper
just went to uh jail for shooting all of
them Megan these stallions feet oh oh
how long's gonna be in jail for 10 years
10 years
isn't that crazy here's here's what's up
with me and I'm I I've known this for a
while now but I really it really sort of
sunk in even further when I read about
that I don't want anybody to go to jail
almost ever you have to actually kill
someone
or commit like a really violent
otherwise violent crime uh or
I mean there are Financial crimes I
guess but even though I'm like oh damn
talk about years in jail I know a lot of
time the financial crime is just like I
just got caught up you know you're like
oh like what yeah I do know he I do know
exactly what he did he shot her foot but
even then right I know exactly like Joe
Pesci yeah he was he was actually saying
dance dance dance and shot her feet at
her feet and like bullet shrapnel got
lodged in her feet and everything and at
first she actually lied to the cops
because she didn't want him to get in
trouble and then eventually she
obviously told the truth and she ended
up having to take the stand she says it
like ruined her life which I totally
understand it's double traumatic you
gotta actually have that experience and
then you gotta actually go through all
the courtroom procedures yeah to make
the guy go to jail you know what I don't
get is if somebody he has no chance of
parole which is the craziest part
some violation he committed during the
trial or something like that there's no
there's some like rule that he broke
that says he if he's found guilty
there's no chance of pearl so he's going
to be in jail for 10 years no matter
what for being Joe Pesci
and Joe Pesci got off scot-free because
she never went to jail so hold on so
well his head was in a vice right wasn't
that him he got killed well no he put a
guy's head in advice and at the end of
that movie he got beat with aluminum
baseball bats kicked into a hole